tonight holy smokes what Vincent is
about to move and and he takes it takes
on C3 yes he takes on cease and look at
Magnus he looks aside it's clearly
indicates that he has noticed Knight
takes E4 but it was so tempting for
Vincent he thinks like glow is enough I
treat the Queens what can happen to me
it's a very solid position but Magus
cannot believe he is look at this he's
just completely shocked of what happened
oh my gosh a huge Miss by Vincent but
let's not overstate the case he's got
fantastic chances of holding that end
game but my goodness Knight takes C4
would have likely sent him into the next
round so easy to miss against anybody
but particularly from a nut nothing
position out of the Clear Blue Sky a
tactic like this is exceedingly hard to
see so definitely understandable Vincent
playing the move quickly and I wonder if
magnus's reaction maybe tipped him off
to the fact that something existed and